>> Laura: DEPUTY F.B.I.
COMMITTEE AFTER 7 1/2 HOURS
UNRAVELING THE INSURANCE POLICY
TEXT.
PAUL WISE ENBURG WHO CONDUCTED
QUESTIONING OF BILL CLINTON IN
THE WHITEWATER INVESTIGATION.
SAUL, WOW, 7 1/2 HOURS, EVEN IF
I'M TONGUE TIED AT THE TOP
THERE.
7 1/2 HOURS FOR MCCABE, WHAT
DOES THAT TELL YOU, IF ANYTHING?
>> IT TELLS YOU THEY'RE VERY
ANGRY AT HIM.
YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT THE
PERSON WHO WOULDN'T UNDERSTAND
A CONFLICT OF INTEREST IF IT
JUMPED UP AND BIT HIM ON THE
BUTT.
THEY'VE BEEN WAITING TO TALK TO
HIM FOR A LONG TIME.
MY GOD, YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT A
LAWYER WHOSE WIFE TOOK $700,000
FROM A CLINTON CRONY AND HE
REFUSED TO RECUSE HIMSELF FROM
THE CLINTON INVESTIGATIONS
UNTIL THERE WAS A "WALL STREET
THEY WERE CLOSED.
>> Laura: REPUBLICANS, MORE OF
THEM, ARE COMING CLOSER AND AT
LEAST ONE CALLING FOR HIM TO
STEP ASIDE.
I THINK A LOT OF FOLKS ARE
HESITANT TO SAY THAT ABOUT
MUELLER ALTHOUGH SOME ARE.
BUT IT SEEMS TO ME GIVEN
EVERYTHING WE KNOW ABOUT MCCABE
FROM HIS WIFE TO THE
CONVERSATION OR THEY LEARNED
SOMETHING ABOUT THAT
CONVERSATION, I IMAGINE, THAT
TOOK PLACE BEFORE THE ELECTION
THAT MR. STRZOK WAS REFERRING
TO IN THOSE TEXTS ABOUT AN
INSURANCE POLICY.
AND AT THIS POINT I THINK HE IS
THE WEAKEST LINK AT THE F.B.I.
IN THIS CURRENT SITUATION.
>> LAURA, NOBODY OVER AT THE
BUREAU CAN BELIEVE -- I TALKED
TO FORMER AGENTS, I TALKED TO
PEOPLE WHO ARE CURRENTLY AT THE
STILL THERE.
IT'S ASTONISHING THAT HE IS
I WOULDN'T TARNISH MUELLER.
I NOTICE YOU DIDN'T PASS UP THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TARNISH BOB
MUELLER WITH MCCABE.
I WOULDN'T DO THAT.
MUELLER HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
THE THINGS THAT MCCABE DID
BEFORE MUELLER CAME ONTO THE
SCENE.
TEXT FROM STRZOK, WHAT POSSIBLE
INNOCENT EXPLANATION IS THERE?
HE SAYS WE CAN'T TAKE THE RISK
THAT TRUMP WILL BE ELECTED.
WE CAN'T TAKE THE RISK.
I MEAN, HOW CAN YOU -- THERE
ARE ONLY EMBARRASSING AND MORE
EMBARRASSING EXPLANATIONS.
THERE IS NO COMPLETELY INNOCENT
EXPLANATION FOR THAT.
WORST CASE SCENARIO IS -- GO
AHEAD.
>> Laura: GO AHEAD.
THE WORST CASE SCENARIO IS THEY
WERE TRYING TO STOP TRUMP FROM
BECOMING ELECTED AND GET THAT
FISA WARRANT ON THE PHONY BASIS
OF THE DOSSIER.
THEY WERE ACTUALLY TRYING TO IN
A WAY HELP TRUMP IF HE WERE
ELECTED BY GETTING FINISHED
WITH THIS INVESTIGATION,
CORRECT?
ALSO HEARD A RUMOR FLOATING
AROUND THE INSURANCE POLICY WAS
FOR THEM TO KEEP THEIR JOBS,
WHICH IS EQUALLY RIDICULOUS.
AN F.B.I. AGENT DOESN'T HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT -- AT THAT LEVEL
DOESN'T HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT
KEEPING THEIR JOB IN A NEW
ADMINISTRATION UNLESS THEY'VE
COMMITTED MALFEASANCE.
UNLESS HE WAS WORRIED ABOUT HIS
HANDLING OF THE CLINTON EMAIL
INVESTIGATION, I'M TALKING
IT'S A PREPOSTEROUS EXPLANATION.
THE MOST INNOCENT EXPLANATION
IS WE CAN'T TAKE THE RISK THAT
HE IS GOING TO GET ELECTED AND
NOT LET US INVESTIGATE HIM SO
LET'S GET THIS INVESTIGATION
STARTED NOW.
BUT EVEN THERE IT'S OBVIOUS
THEY ARE RUSHING THINGS AND NOT
DOING IT THE RIGHT WAY AND THE
METICULOUS WAY.
>> Laura: I HAVE A QUESTION FOR
YOU.
I MEAN, THAT DOESN'T BEAR ON
THE RUSSIAN INVESTIGATION.
I KNOW HE RECUSED HIMSELF FROM
THE COLLUSION INVESTIGATION,
WHY COUNT HE FIRE MCCABE NOW?
HE COULD, RIGHT?
>> HE HAS THE POWER TO FIRE
MCCABE.
I'VE HEARD DIFFERENT THINGS HOW
BROAD HIS RECUSAL WAS.
ONE INTERPRETATION HE SAID I
WON'T HAVE ANYTHING TO DO WITH
THE ELECTION AT ALL.
SOMEBODY COULD SAY THAT HAS TO
DO WITH THE ELECTION.
BUT I THINK HE COULD DO IT.
LOOK, PRESIDENT TRUMP CAN CALL
UP CHRISTOPHER WRAY AND SAY THE
GUY SHOULDN'T BE THERE.
>> Laura: HE WILL BE ATTACKED
FOR IT.
>> HE IS ATTACKED FOR
EVERYTHING, YOU KNOW.
>> Laura: HE WON'T DO IT.
I THINK YOU'RE PROBABLY RIGHT.
IN THE END HE PROBABLY